la foire de chatou est la plus grande
foire de france elle réunit pendant dix
jours plus de 400 antiquaires et
brocanteurs toujours ravi d'être là il
ya toujours une bonne ambiance c'est une
bonne foire avec plein de stands et de
marchandises de différentes voilà il y
en a un peu pour pour tous les goûts
cette année la foire sera un peu
particulière en raison de la situation
sanitaire
tu as plus de mille personnes en même
temps sur le site et gels hydro
alcooliques sur tous les stands et
surtout masque obligatoire ceva hyper
pratique de travailler en termes de
relations commerciales avec un masque
effectivement c'est le plus compliqué
pour créer le contact le dialogue et
c'est bon on n'a pas le choix donc on le
fait malgré ces mesures les
organisateurs espèrent attirer 30 mille
personnes la foire de chatou se
distingue par la variété d'objets
proposés à la vente
antiquaires et brocanteurs se côtoient
c'est vraiment une fois de passionnés
nous sommes antiquaires en passionné qui
transmettront à d'autres passionnés qui
vont venir à la pendant ces dix jours
d'ouverture qui vont se faire un plaisir
de venir chiner des reculé dans les
allées et pour les prix il y à du tout
au niveau budget au niveau budget ce qui
est fantastique h à tous ces cons on
peut acheter un arrosoir à 5 euros en
zinc et acheter des pièces à des
milliers d'euros cette année le prix
saint roch le patron des antiquaires
sera remis à yves lecoq